[Music]
about an hour before you're ready to
serve Christmas dinner it's time to cook
the final dishes and make the finishing
touches first I'm getting Mom to help
cook my chili and turmeric roasted
potatoes this dish is another Twist on
tradition it gives the potatoes a lovely
color and their spicy kick helps
compliment and lift the whole Christmas
meal we're just going to do again little
twist of the potatoes we doing need some
goose fat are we uh no
no oh God goose fat we're going to do a
really nice um lightly spiced roast
potato okay little chili flake chili
yeah chili flake just to put a little
bit of heat in there for the Christmas
lunch yep chili flake and a little bit
of turmeric I can't believe you're doing
roast potatoes for
chili now would you be so kind just to
give them a little cut cut the peeled
potatoes into quarters and put into
salted cold water in they
go okay bring them up to the boil and
simmer for around 8 minutes drain and
let them steam then season with salt and
pepper on there and just a little
teaspoon of chili flake oh no that's the
sort of thing I would make for supper in
a Saturday night or something like that
you know
really chili flakes in add a teaspoon of
turmeric turmeric is a member of the
ginger family it stains the potatoes a
wonderful golden color and adds a lovely
earthy
taste next drizzle in a little olive oil
and Shake to coat them just let them
roll around yeah that smells nice
beautiful could you get me the uh
stuffing please from the fridge put in a
preheated baking tray with extra olive
oil and cook at 200° C for about 40
minutes give a little shake to make sure
they don't
stick and then I'll just stick the
stuffing than up on top here now that
will take roughly about the same time
time as potatoes stuffing in potatoes
done nice why are you going to play with
the kids oh we'll do yeah okay see you
shortly thank you
bye-bye